dozens of news producers who oversee
websites for Microsoft are being
replaced by machines managers of the
software company have decided to switch
to artificial intelligence to select and
edit news media reports in Seattle where
the company is based say that around 15
used producers in both the US and
Britain won't have their contracts
renewed Microsoft says the decision
isn't related to the pandemic Mira Selda
is a director at the Reuters Institute
for the Study of journalism at Oxford
University and she joins us live now
good to have you with us this situation
we have to say that it's not unique to
Microsoft is it No all media
organizations have been looking at
automation and AI in different ways to
see if they can use it to tailor their
news towards their audiences or readers
or to kind of curate a front page or
great products so it's not new and it's
also not new that jobs are being cut
across the industry sadly it's a very
difficult time and there are nails in
several several editions but can new
stories be written curated aggregated
effectively by artificial intelligence
no not purely artificial intelligence
you always need journalists and this
particular story is what Microsoft is
doing is related to news curation not
news production so it's who the stories
are still being produced by journalists
but how they're put on the front page at
the moment they're put on the front page
of the websites by humans and this is
the thing that's going to be automated
it does raise issues humans can look at
a cultural context they can look at an
overview and make sure there's a proper
variety of views represented on it on a
webpage they can make sure there's no
particular bias towards one political
opinion rather than another and they
understand the cultural nuances of
already in any given space so they're
less likely to put up something's that
are openly offensive to some one part of
the community for example in other words
you're saying that this has the
potential to to help the spread of fake
news and misinformation or
disinformation misinformation it is a
danger that depending on who writes the
code how it's written and what
story what's what sources it uses to
pull up news stories so there is a
danger that news that has been
deliberately created to be false
misinformation or fake news appears on a
page because it hasn't been caught by
human eyes and we've seen with them
companies like Facebook and Twitter that
when they haven't had human curation
when they tried to rely on automation
they're going to deep trouble with this
so I still be reading stories that are
written by by human beings by
journalists but there'll be the order in
which they appear on the page will be
selected by by AI that's right that
seems to be the idea and the thing to
remember here is that kiem it's not a
it's not a neutral platform it's Ares is
written by code and the code is written
by human beings
so the whoever is writing the codes has
their own biases and their own
prejudices so what what does the AI
decide is the important news story is it
something that would only appeal to the
kind of person walls are of the code or
is it broad enough to to be more
sophisticated than that really good to
talk to you mirror many thanks indeed
Mira solo that in Oxford thank you